[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on s'est beaucoup passionné temps à
colombes qu'à marseille pour les demi
finales de la coupe de france de
football à colombes ce sont les
bordelais maillot à chevrons et les
sedanais qui s'efforce de gagner le
droit de participer à la finale sedan
prend une option en marquant le premier
but par son avant-centre mouchel options
de courte durée puisqu'une minute à
peine s'est écoulée lorsque les
bordelais égalise tout est remise en
question
sedan cependant reprend l'avantagé en
deuxième mi temps
le sort de la partie par est réglé et
bien non les bordeaux n'est décidément
très en verve cette année en coupe de
france arrachent le match nul à
marseille scénario presque identique
c'est l'équipe de première division
nîmes maillot foncé qui marque le
premier but devant montpellier
[Applaudissements]
les nîmois obtiennent un second but
surprise en deuxième mi temps
on croit alors que les joueurs de
montpellier vont baisser les bras pas du
tout mais les montpelliérains ne peuvent
que réduire le score à 2-1
voici revenu le temps où les beaux jours
réveil le démon de l'aventuré qui
sommeille dans le coeur de chaque
citadin le temps des explorateurs comme
des paysans du dimanche
[Musique]
et que de découvertes ne peut faire un
oeil neuf à travers de vraies lunettes
de soleil au hasard des secrets et des
travaux d'une ferme la moindre scène de
la vie quotidienne il vient un tableau
idyllique
dès qu'on la considère à travers des
verts réellement absorbant et sans doute
en s'attachant à protéger la vue du
soleil sans départ et un joli visage
les opticiens français n'avait il pas
songé que leur création pourrait être
autant de moyens de transfigurer les
petites servitudes de la vie campagnarde
[Musique]
il n'en faut pas douter le secours de la
lunetterie est aujourd'hui aussi
nécessaire aux aventuriers du week end
que le masque respiratoire au découvreur
de l'espace le monde est tellement plus
gentils comme ça
[Musique]
le gaz d'éclairage et sa production
locale appartiennent au passé
depuis 47 375 petite usine ou disparus
aujourd'hui le dispatching central de
paris règne sur un réseau de
canalisations qui se développe chaque
jour une telle transformation de
l'économie gazière a été rendue possible
par la création de centrales géantes
comme celle d'alfortville qui sont les
coeurs mécanique d'un immense système
circulatoire
ici le robot est roi des détecteurs
automatiques surveille les tapis
roulants
qu'ils arrêtent au passage de corps
étrangers indésirables
chargement des fours défournement du coq
sont pratiquement réalisé sans aucune
intervention humaine sinon de
surveillance de gaz produit est absorbé
par un monde surréaliste de conduite
auquel viennent se mêler les
canalisations du gaz naturel de lacs et
du gaz fabriqué en lorraine dosé
mélanger le gaz entre alors dans les
compresseurs dont l'ensemble constitue
une réalisation sans égal en europe
l'homme n'intervient qu'au niveau des
boutons images des temps nouveaux le gaz
de france est placé à la pointe du
progrès
[Musique]
c'est l'instinct de suspense sur
l'aérodrome de moscou des milliers de
regards se sont concentrés sur l'homme
en uniforme qui descend d'avion
youri alexeïevitch gagarine le président
coach of avait voulu être le premier à
le serrer dans ses bras il le fit dans
l' enthousiasme
[Applaudissements]
mais youri gagarine embrassa un père et
une mère dont on imagine l'émotion
[Applaudissements]
le jour j'ai comme gagarine avait
commencé pour moscou une ovation
ininterrompue a conduit l'homme de
l'espace jusqu'à la place rouge et à la
tribune du mausolée de lénine la foule
qu'on a évalué à plus d'un million de
personnes a pu acclamer à loisir l'homme
qui peut le premier se vanter d'avoir vu
de ses yeux la terre ronde comme une
boule et d'avoir vécu la plus
extraordinaire aventure du siècle
sa dernière visite le général de gaulle
l'a consacré au sud-ouest et l'accueil
de périgueux où le chef de l'état s'est
recueilli devant le cénotaphe de la
résistance fut à l'image de celui de
chacune des villes traversées à l'image
de celui de bordeaux où il accueilli le
maire monsieur chaban delmas dans chaque
ville le général de gaulle avait choisi
d'évoquer l'algérie est la capitale du
sud ouest l'a entendu réaffirmé le
double but de la france
la paix et l'association
et là que nous offrons à tous les
algériens y compris d'abord bien sûr
ceux qui jusqu'à présent refusait de
prendre les mains que nous entendons
l'algérie nouvelle si elle le veut fera
son tueur chemin aux côtés la france
nouvelle
dans sa cage de verre à l'épreuve des
balles
iceman une silhouette banal un phase
trois juges
rien de spectaculaire nous sommes
cependant peut-être devant le plus
énorme et le plus étrange procès de
l'histoire car sous les phrases sans
relief de l'acte d'accusation
ce sont 5 millions de juifs qui parle
cinq millions de morts
car iceman fut dans ce qui fut appelé
l'ordre nazi celui qui eut pour mission
d'organiser la solution finale du
problème juif et l'on sait ce que l'on
doit entendre par là aux contes
d'hoffmann le boycottage sociale
l'arrestation arbitraire la suppression
des droits civiques de ce qu'ils étaient
juifs bagatelle de la porte mais la
porte s'ouvrait sur quoi elle ouvrait
sur la rafle le camp de concentration et
le reste c'est iceman l'inventeur de
l'étoile jaune c'est iceman le créateur
du camp de drancy qui reste dans la
mémoire des français c'est iceman le
créateur du travail obligatoire pour ces
foules qui n'avait à attendre ni secours
ni pitié le travail obligatoire et tout
ce que pouvait dissimuler ce vocable
innocent c'est ashman l'organisateur
dahouche beats à auschwitz qui est
signée ice man of shit qui fut à
proprement parler le camp où l'on entré
par la porte mais de l'on sortait par la
cheminée
5 millions de juifs passèrent par cet
enclos sinistre ou le gaz cyclone permis
de donner à la mort la productivité
industrielle indispensable à la solution
finale du problème juif
iceman aussi la création des fours
crématoires qui achevait l'oeuvre du gaz
tic l' iceman l'organisateur sans défaut
cette idée de récupération totale qui
des cheveux des cadavres alors des
dentiers des chaussures aux vêtements
transforma le tortionnaire en
chiffonniers et jusqu'au locke et
jusqu'aux appareils de prothèses et cela
c'est peut-être au delà de l'horreur
[Musique]
au cours des semaines encore la
séparation des familles cette misère et
cette abjection ou tombent l'homme dans
la promiscuité des camps
[Musique]
à lui aussi la honte des expériences
scientifiques sur des cobayes humains
telles celles qui réunit une centaine de
jumeaux et nous ne faisons que citer les
chefs d'accusation
[Musique]
à iceman toujours l'abomination dernière
d'avoir condamné même des enfants à la
claustration à la famine à la maladie à
la folie et à la mort iceman écoute et
répond le plus étrange est même qu'il
écoute et qu'il réponde dans saisie
qu'est ce qu'il y a au fond de cet homme
que peut-on faire d'un iceman
[Musique]